day 22 of the general election campaign
I'm in cheshire key battleground for
conservative labor seats in fact 28
marginals across the northwest and I've
been on the conservative battle bus on
cameron's coach itself interviewing the
Prime Minister what's really quite
marked about today is just how much the
Conservatives are doubling up on the
campaign seeking to link the SNP to a
labor minority government that inputs
the SNP launching their manifesto in
edinburgh today and the Conservatives
almost whoop it every time the SNP would
announce or make some comments that
seemed to do suggest some sort of malign
influence over a potential labour
minority government it makes the
conservative case for them they think
the bigger point here though is that the
Conservatives can now if you like by
default attack Mr Miliband and labor
without getting personal about them by
raising the prospect of the SMP bad for
labor in Scotland in terms of seats good
they think for the English voters who
don't like the idea of an unstable
with SMP influence even though Nicola
Sturgeon it's not quite as unpopular as
they think well what about the
Conservatives they they themselves did a
deal minority government support for the
SNP itself holyrood Mr Cameron telling
me he thinks that's a world of
difference that day 22